nos preguntan cuál en la menor suma de
cuadrados posible para dos números con
producto menos 16 ok esto ya que es un
problema de optimización y lo que vamos
a hacer es plantear el problema con
algunas variables y después resolverlo
con lo que hemos platicado de derivadas
entonces empecemos con esto con dos
números vale entonces a esos dos números
vamos a ponerle vamos a ponerles xy ya
va entonces nos preguntan por la menor
suma de cuadrados es decir queremos
minimizar ese igual a x al cuadrado
déjame ponerle un poco más grande porque
creo que tengo suficiente espacio ese es
igual a x al cuadrado más ye al cuadrado
va a hay que minimizar esta expresión y
además de esos dos números sabemos que
su producto que su producto es igual a
menos 16 lo voy a escribir por acá xy es
igual a menos 16 ahora aquí tenemos dos
variables x y pero nosotros sabemos
hacer las cosas nada más con una
entonces el chiste es intentar obtener
únicamente expresiones en términos de
una variable digamos x y trabajar con
esa variable en términos de cálculo
entonces por ejemplo de aquí podemos
despejar
para obtener en función de x y luego
sustituirlo acá para hacer esto aquí
despejamos ye dividiendo entre x ambos
lados y nos queda que es igual a menos
16 dividido entre x sale aquí ya tenemos
una expresión de g en términos de x que
poniendo laca obtenemos que s es igual a
x al cuadrado más y aquí vamos a poner
que es menos 16 entre x entre x elevado
al cuadrado muy bien desarrollando esto
un poquito nos queda que ese es ese y
aquí ya le podemos poner ese de x porque
ya nada más depende de x es igual a x al
cuadrado más y aquí vamos a desarrollar
esto menos 16 al cuadrado es 16 x 16 3
256 menos por menos es más
entonces nos queda más 256 dividido
entre x cuadrada pero lo voy a escribir
como x a la menos 2 para que sea más
fácil derivar sale entonces estoy acá ya
es la suma de cuadrados expresada en una
sola variable entonces ya podemos
derivar encontrar los puntos críticos
o ver dónde bueno donde no está definida
la derivada y entonces podríamos
encontrar el mínimo sale entonces vamos
a hacer eso déjame escribir la derivada
acá con este color verde acá a la
derecha entonces si estoy acá ssd x s
prima de x vamos a derivar nos quedaría
igual a derivamos x al cuadrado baja el
2 y queda x a la 1 y luego hay que sumar
otra vez derivando está esta potencia es
x a la menos 2 al menos 2 baja menos 2
por 256 es menos 512 menos 512 por x
sala y el exponente baja en uno de menos
2 pasa a menos 3 x a la menos 3 muy bien
entonces tenemos dos posibilidades para
puntos críticos uno es cuando se anula
la derivada y otro es cuando no está
definida aquí vamos a ver cuando nuestra
definida pues el 2x no tiene problema
pero esto como es dividir entre x al
cubo no está definido cuando x es igual
a 0
pero bueno igual si x es igual a 0 y
está también dividido entre entre x o
sea dividido entre 0 entonces tampoco
está definido así que no le vamos a
hacer caso a ese caso de ahí porque ya
sería bueno podemos pensarlo como
infinito entonces pues no sería la menor
suma bueno entonces la otra opción es
que esta derivada sea igual a cero es
decir que 2x menos 512 x a la menos 3
sea igual a cero ok vamos a despejar x
de aquí sumamos 512 x a la menos 3 de
ambos lados nos quedaría que 2x es igual
a 512 porque quizá la menos 3 y pues
multiplicando por x al cubo de ambos
lados
tendríamos que 2x a la cuarta es igual a
aquí y x al cubo por x a la menos 3 se
hace 12 x a la cuarta es igual a 512
dividiendo entre 2 ambos lados el 2 se
cancela nos queda x a la cuarta igual a
256 ok
entonces ahora tenemos que encontrar el
valor de x que satisface
cómo le hacemos pues tenemos que sacar
raíz cuadrada verdad nos queda que quizá
al cuadrado es igual a 16 a 16 digo
sacando la raíz aquí podría ser 16 o
menos 16 pero este es un número positivo
entonces sólo puede ser 16 y sacando
raíz cuadrada una vez más tenemos que x
es igual a 4 o menos 4 pero como lo como
el producto de los números es menos 16 1
es positivo y otro es negativo podemos
pensar que xe es el positivo vale déjame
ponerle por acá que x es el que es mayor
o igual que 0 entonces ya es menor o
igual que 0 para que nos quede negativo
entonces x es igual a 4 ya tenemos este
punto crítico y como es el único punto
crítico pues muy seguramente nos va a
ayudar a encontrar la menor suma de
cuadrados posibles pero bueno digo por
si las dudas no vaya a ser que no vamos
a hacer el criterio de la segunda
derivada entonces aquí ya tenemos la
derivada la la primera derivada déjame
pasar a a este color azul claro entonces
vamos a hacer la segunda derivada aquí
s segunda derivada de x s de prima
esto de aquí es igual a aquí derivando
2x nos quedan 2 y luego nos queda este
la derivada de esto de acá que es menos
3 por 512 negativo x a la menos cuatro o
sea haber menos por menos es más aquí
nos quedan más tres por 512 3 por
506.500 3 por 12 36 entonces es 1536 y
luego x nos queda elevado a la menos 4
muy bien observa esto es dividir entre
quizá la cuarta y equis a la cuarta
siempre es positivo entonces esto es
positivo esto es positivo y de este modo
la segunda derivada siempre es mayor o
igual que hicieron como se vería el
dibujito esto lo que nos dice que la
segunda derivada sea mayor o igual que 0
es que la función s tiene una gráfica
que es cóncava hacia arriba que se ve
más o menos así sea como una u entonces
el hecho bueno de que la segunda
derivada sea mayor o igual que 0 es que
la primera derivada empieza digamos
negativa déjame ponerlo con este
cual combinaría viene el blanco entonces
entonces la derivada empieza sin
negativa pero la segunda derivada es
mayor o igual que 0 entonces la derivada
va creciendo cada vez se está menos
inclinada a la pendiente menos inclinada
aquí se hace 0 en el mínimo verdad y
luego sube y sube sube va entonces una
segunda derivada mayor o igual que 0 nos
da una función cóncava hacia arriba y de
esta forma cuando la derivada de cero
tenemos un mínimo así que en efecto x es
igual a 4 nos va a dar el mínimo bueno
pero nosotros queremos encontrar la suma
de cuadrados ya sabemos el valor de x
ahora tenemos que encontrar el valor de
bank entonces qué tendríamos déjame
ponerlo con este color verde para
indicar que viene de acá entonces sería
igual a menos 16 dividido entre cuatro
porque x vale 4 o sea que ya sería igual
a menos 4 a eso está bueno verdad que es
menor o igual que 0 como esperábamos
porque x es mayor o igual que 0 y el
producto es menos 16 están los dos
números con producto menos 16 y
finalmente regresando a la suma de
cuadrados
tendríamos que la suma de cuadrados es
igual a x al cuadrado sea 4 al cuadrado
más menos 4 al cuadrado menos 4 al
cuadrado que es igual a 16 16 verdad
menos al cuadrado es más que es igual a
32 muy bien aquí tenemos el resultado y
a lo mejor puedes decir oye no sé a lo
mejor yo yo sí o sí va a encontrar estos
valores estamos muy facilito el problema
me estás diciendo que tienen producto
menos 16 entonces es muy natural pensar
en 4 y menos 4 entonces a lo mejor
comprobando 4 y menos 4 y 2 y menos 8 y
menos 8 y 2 y 116 y va a sacar esta
solución y bueno sí pero ojo aquí nunca
nos dicen que los números son enteros
entonces en realidad de vista de haber
secado todos todos los casos no sólo x
igual a 1234 y aquí sino x igual a 4.333
o 4.01 o no sé 44 más bio lo que sea
entonces pues realmente había muchos
casos que checar y bueno incluso pudo
haber pasado que este producto no fuera
menos 16 este producto pudo haber sido
17 o menos 19 o una cosa más fea si por
ejemplo pi cuadrada entre entre 8 y
cuadrado entre 2
entonces en este caso no iba a ser tan
fácil poder probar todos los números de
hecho no ibas a poder probar todos los
números hay una infinidad pero haciendo
estas cuentas de cálculo si se hubiera
optimizado la suma de cuadrados así
igualito bueno le voy a dejar hasta aquí
nos vemos hasta la próxima